and so now it's just that's not about  making gay marriage illegal it's legal  in every single state  that was always their big fight no now  it's about making your kids gay  why don't no why else would you want to  have  two dudes or two women kissing in a  disney film what is maybe because that  exists in the real world then you want  to be representative of the real world  charlie the agenda to expose them to it  or to increase the ranks of the lgbtq  community  what is the process  people were gay  before this sort of  nonsense was happening so why exactly  are you doing this  and of course the answer's so simple  that that it's just to represent the way  the real world is  don't they get the idea is we're just  going to represent that in the world  there's different types of people